trois mots pour décrire la salle de nuit
mercuriel égoïste obsédé par soi c'est
quatre mots mais
[Musique]
Je pensais seulement que Donald Trump
allait être une belle histoire bonne mauvaise ou
sinon
en fait la majeure partie de la journée est passée à
regarder la télévision sa journée de travail est un
bref, c'est de la fin de la
matinée à la fin de l'après-midi et la majeure partie
est remplie de réunions
organisées par ses réunions d'équipe avec des
groupes de personnes de supporters qui entrent
dans le bureau ovale, puis ils
lui offrent d'énormes éloges
et à leur tour  il leur offre en retour il
leur dit que vous êtes le plus grand
le plus grand le plus important et je ferai n'importe
quoi pour vous à tout moment donc c'est un
cercle de flatterie c'est je veux dire c'est un
peu je veux dire c'est en fait tout un
peu effrayant tu sais je pense  Je pense
que cela pourrait être l'histoire de
sa chambre. La première chose quand il est entré,
il avait une télévision dans
la chambre et il avait deux autres
télévisions installées, puis quand il
a fait une crise quand ils ont nettoyé sa
chambre et que quelqu'un a ramassé sa chemise
et il a dit que si la chemise est par terre,
c'est parce que je veux qu'elle soit par
terre, puis il a dit et il a dit de ne jamais
toucher ma brosse à dents et de ne pas  changer mes
draps si je veux que mes draps soient changés je
vais dépouiller le lit alors euh c'était moi Je
ne sais pas ce que cela signifie et
je ne suis pas sûr de vouloir savoir ce que
cela signifie
[Musique
] c'est un livre  à propos de son à propos de son
personnel à propos des personnes qui lui sont les plus
proches c'est une histoire de ces personnes des
professionnels des personnes raisonnablement bonnes
commençant dans la certitude passant à la
perplexité passant à la confusion
jusqu'à la désillusion et enfin à l'
incrédulité où littéralement à cent
pour cent de l'aîné  le personnel en est venu à
douter de sa capacité à
occuper ce poste, il est le président des États-
Unis, il était il a été dûment élu maintenant, car
il se trouve qu'un grand nombre de personnes
qui sont entrées à la Maison Blanche avec lui
le 20 janvier 2017 ont hav  Nous sommes déjà
partis en fait, l'exode de
cette Maison Blanche a été vraiment
aussi aussi important que l'exode qui se
produit généralement à la fin d'un premier mandat, donc
dans un certain sens, la situation ne cesse
d'empirer qu'il n'y a que là
C'est en fait très difficile pour cette
Maison Blanche d'embaucher de nouvelles personnes parce que
tout le monde a peur d'aller travailler pour
Donald Trump
[Musique]
sous-sol